Heute im Rasenfunk?
Blick auf andere Jungen. Was viele nicht wissen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da draußen ist, das war jetzt gar nicht das eigentliche Intro, sondern das waren wir, die das live eingesprochen haben, denn so enthusiastisch sind wir heute morgen in der Liga Tour und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und hier begrüße ich bei mir zum einen Fabian Pakulat. Hallo Fabian. Mario Rieker, hi Mario. Und Uli Hebel. Servus Uli. Ja, wir sind absolut hyped. So kann man das glaube ich sagen, das war hier ein wahrer Rave, bevor wir losgelegt haben. Aber gut, es ist für uns alle sehr früh und viele von uns haben auch noch nachts gearbeitet. Das ist keine gute Kombination, aber für euch machen wir das natürlich trotzdem und das alles, obwohl der Rasenfunk reinspendenfinanziert ist oder vielleicht gerade weil er reinspendenfinanziert ist. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub, da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und bitte tut das auch und empfehlt gerne auch diese Sendung weiter. Und dann würde ich sagen, gar nicht lange drum rum schnacken, sondern wir legen direkt los. Wir wollen heute ein bisschen sprechen über La Liga, die Serie A und die Premier League. Die Ligue 1 hat es leider nicht geschafft. Die war zu motiviert. Unsere League-R-Experten waren alle zu hype. Da haben wir gesagt, das überlastet diese Sendung. Hoffentlich schaffen wir es wieder zum nächsten Mal. Aber diesmal war es nicht möglich. Und jetzt ist die große Frage, wo wir loslegen. Ich glaube, wir beginnen in Spanien, denn Fabian ist schon am längsten hier im Call, hat schon am meisten von seinem Enthusiasmus versprüht. Und jetzt darfst du uns direkt drüber retten. Auch du hast wieder zwei Themen mitgebracht, Fabian. Such dir aus, mit was du beginnst.
Ja, es sind beide positive Themen und es geht beide Male um athletische Mannschaften, sozusagen. Ich möchte gern sprechen über Atletico Madrid und Atletico Bilbao. Und ich fange am besten mal mit Atletico Madrid an. Vielleicht, wenn man ein paar Liga-Touren schon verfolgt hat, bin ich jetzt nicht der größte Fan von Diego Simeone und seinem Spielstil. Aber ich möchte ihm gerne zugute halten, dass es im Moment richtig gut läuft bei Atletico Madrid. Und zwar spielerisch wie auch von den Ergebnissen her mit einem Antoine Griezmann, der im Moment ja seinen dritten, vierten Frühling hat oder fünften, sechsten schon. Und ja, ich habe so ein bisschen auch das Gefühl, die Abgänge von João Felix zum FC Barcelona und von Carrasco hat dem Spiel eher gut getan. Denn jetzt hat, glaube ich, Simeone wieder seine Guerreros zusammen, seine Krieger, die wirklich ja voll das machen, was er von seinem Team erwartet. Und das funktioniert richtig gut. Und hervorzuheben ist vielleicht da vor allen Dingen eben das Sturmduo mit Grießmann und Alvaro Morata, dem spanischen Nationalstürmer, der ja auch oft belächelt wurde, auch von mir oder ja, auch von den spanischen Medien, der aber zweifelsohne seine Tode macht und im Moment wieder richtig gut knips, gestern auch in der Champions League ein sehr sehenswertes Tor gemacht hat. Und die beiden zusammen, Grießmann und Morata, harmonieren dort richtig gut im Sturm und haben dann noch nebenbei ja als Backup sozusagen ein Memphis dabei und ein Angel Correa. Und das ist schon sehr ordentlich, muss ich sagen, derzeit bei Atletico.
Also aktuell vierter Tabellenplatz, 22 Punkte, aber noch ein Spiel weniger als die meisten anderen Teams. Das heißt, man könnte ausschließen Zorreal und Cirona, die an der Spitze stehen aktuell. Kannst du mir das mal erklären, wie das möglich ist, wie lange ist Simeone jetzt bei Atletico? 1982 so ungefähr, also gefühlt zumindest. Wie schafft man das mit diesem ja doch sehr intensiven Spielstil, das immer durchziehen zu können und immer wieder, also ich schaue es mir an, 23 zu 8 Tore und nichts davon überrascht mich. Also am ehesten noch die 23, könnten auch 12 zu 8 Tore sein, mit derselben Anzahl von Punkten. Aber gut, Grießmann hat halt gerade einen Lauf, Murata hast du ja auch schon angesprochen. Aber wie geht denn das eigentlich?
Es ist tatsächlich faszinierend. Ich habe gestern mir auch noch mal die Mannschaft von Atletico Madrid angeguckt und die meiste Position oder die Position, die am meisten vergeben ist im Kader, ist die der Verteidiger, der Defensive. Hat mich jetzt nicht überrascht, aber spricht eigentlich Bände. Und in den letzten Jahren habe ich ja auch immer wieder kritisiert, dass es bei Atletico Madrid nicht so läuft mit dem Budget, das sie haben. Keine spielerische Entwicklung, die neuen Spieler haben nie gegriffen und so weiter. Und im Endeffekt ist es glaube ich schon so, dass der Verein an dem Trainer und an dem System von Simeone festhalten möchte und Kontinuität dort vorgibt, was eine positive Sache ist, wie ich finde. Und Spieler, die da nicht mitziehen oder die da nicht mit können, wie eben jetzt ein Felix oder wie auch immer sie in der Vergangenheit geheißen haben, da waren ja einige große Namen da, die müssen halt dann wieder gehen. Also man hat sich dort glaube ich sehr festgelegt, entweder ihr passt zu uns oder ihr passt eben nicht zu uns. Und dann wird dementsprechend gehandelt. Und die Spieler wissen einfach seit Jahren, was sie erwartet. Und du kannst dann eben als Spieler auch sehr gut selbst einschätzen, bleibe ich dort oder versuche ich mein Glück dann doch lieber woanders. Und die, die im Moment da sind, die wollen auch da sein. Und Qualität hat der Kader, vielleicht nicht so wirklich in zweiter Ebene. Auf der Bank sieht es ein bisschen anders aus. Es gibt ein paar Spieler, wo ich mir nie so ganz sicher bin, wo deren Leistungskurve wirklich ist oder das Leistungstopp. So ein Rodrigo de Paul zum Beispiel von Argentinien, den habe ich noch nicht ganz durchgespielt, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob der wirklich so Weltklasse ist oder nicht. Es gab einen Saul Niguez, der war ja unter anderem auch mal bei Chelsea letztes Jahr. Dort hat er gar nichts gebracht. Bei Atletico wurde davor auch nicht. Große Formkrise gehabt. Der ist jetzt wieder richtig on fire. Es gibt halt Spieler, die funktionieren unter Simeone und es gibt Spieler, die tun es nicht und im Moment sind dort hauptsächlich Spieler, die funktionieren.
Kurze Frage dazu. Ich meine, der von dir angesprochene Rodrigo de Paul, der ist ja gestern wieder damit auffällig geworden, wofür ich ihn auch liebe, nämlich für krasse Crätschen manchmal über dem Limit hinweg. Deswegen ist er in der Champions League direkt vom Platz geflogen. Ist ja eigentlich sonst so ein bisschen Bodyguard von Messi gewesen in der Nationalmannschaft immer, aber es klingt alles super positiv, was du sagst natürlich über die Mannschaft. Und jetzt gestern, ich habe nur so die erste 30 Minuten gegen Celtic gesehen, da fand ich das dann tatsächlich, hat man sich von Celtic dominieren lassen und ohne den jetzt nahe treten zu wollen, finde ich in der Champions League Celtic auch durch die, sagen wir mal, eher geringe Qualität der Liga und die Konkurrenz da, habe mich das dann schon überrascht, wie schwach Atletico da aufgetreten ist tatsächlich, wie erklärst du dir das?
Ja, es ist eine Sache, die ich gestern auch nicht so erwartet habe, ganz ehrlich gesagt. Es ist natürlich nochmal eine andere Geschichte, wie man sich auf Teams in der Liga vorbereiten kann, die kennt man natürlich. Da weiß man es vielleicht einfacher, wie man sich einstellt. Celtic ist jetzt glaube ich auch kein Team, das man ständig verfolgt. Die haben zu Hause natürlich auch, die waren gestern besonders motiviert, es gab da wohl mal ein sehr emotionales Spiel in der Vergangenheit zwischen den beiden und dementsprechend waren die Schotten dort extrem motiviert und vielleicht hat sich auch Atletico dort ein bisschen einschüchtern lassen von der Stimmung vor Ort, die ist ja nicht ohne. Immerhin muss man sagen, haben sie aus einer schlechten Leistung dann noch ein 2-2 geholt, glaube ich waren zweimal in Rückstand und können es am Ende vielleicht sogar mitnehmen.
Jetzt, wenn wir hier schon zwei Kommentatoren haben, mal kurz Hand heben, wer von euch hat Atletico schon mal kommentieren dürfen? Mario überlegt. Uli, muss ich noch entmuten? Ich musste dich kurz muten vorhin, Uli. Dann sag mir doch mal, Uli, muss man da überhaupt dann die Vorbereitung nochmal neu machen oder kann man einfach das, was man vor fünf, sechs Jahren sich erst googelt hat oder zusammengelesen hat, kann man das einfach immer weiter verwenden? Du musst dich nur kurz entmuten.
Ich kann so viel sagen zwischendurch, wenn ich sie mal kommentiert habe, dann habe ich es verdrängt in jedem Fall.
Und die Hörerinnen und Hörer werden jetzt wahrscheinlich raussuchen, dass du sie schon 13 Mal kommentiert hast.
Ich mache es trotzdem immer, dass ich versuche, ein weißes Blatt Papier hinzulegen, nur ganz floskelhaft zu machen. Ich schreibe halt immer das gleiche ab. Ne, im Ernst, es gibt ja eine gar nicht so kleine Fan-Vereinigung in Deutschland von Atletico und die schreiben dir zahlreich, wenn du zu viele Plattitüden bringst. Und ich hoffe, ich bringe sie nicht allzu oft.
Aber ist es denn gerechtfertigt, also kann man diese Plattitüden vermeiden oder ist es einfach nur ein Drumherum- reden um denselben Spielstil?
Nö, ich finde schon, also insbesondere in der Saison, finde ich die schon spielerisch echt zum Teil wenigstens ansprechend. Also nicht so, dass sie sich völlig planlos einfach nur sich in den Rhein stellen und rumholzen, sondern es ist rumholzen mit Plan. Und zum Teil auch ganz ordentlich. Deswegen finde ich, die kommen mir eh immer ein bisschen zu schlecht weg. Also ich habe jetzt auch schon, nachdem ich die Backhand-Doku gesehen habe, nochmal neuerliche Antipathien gegen Diego Simeone entwickelt, aber auch leicht schockiert, dass der echt in der Doku vorkommt. Überrascht bis schockiert. Da ich aber David Beckham durchaus zugetan ist, wie man vielleicht weiß, war ich dann doch eher schockiert. Deswegen will ich jetzt erstmal von dem nichts mehr sehen. Aber grundsätzlich finde ich das gar nicht mal so schlecht. Mich hat es gestern wie Mario auch ein bisschen gewundert, dass auch Simeone dann nach der Nachspielzeit dasteht und sagt so sinngemäß, hu, haben wir ja hier einen Punkt geholt. Das hat mich schon auch ein bisschen gewundert gegen Celtic, aber vielleicht ist das auch Teil der Folklore.
Aber Uli, hast du die Simeone-Doku damals gesehen?
Ich weiß, du hast mir das schon mal gesagt, dass ich das tun sollte, weil die gar nicht so verkehrt ist. Aber es gibt zu viele im Moment. Ich habe noch nicht mal Newcastle gesehen und dann weiß man schon...
Ach, zu Newcastle, siehst du, die habe ich nicht mal mitbekommen. Ja, es sind wirklich zu viele Dokus und es fängt auch immer alles gleich an. Also wenn ich noch einmal diesen Zusammenschnitt wilder Szenen aus einer Saison sehe und dann kommt groß der Doku-Titel und dann Schnittbild. Du siehst irgendwie eine Fahne im Wind oder so, dann hörst du Stollen, die über den Platz laufen, ein erster Ball, der getreten wird, ein Pfiff und dann geht es los mit dem ersten O-Ton aus dem offenen. Dann ist es irgendein Spieler, der sagt, ja, damals im September 2023, da wussten wir noch gar nicht, was uns erwarten würde. Ja, die Machart dieser Dokus ist immer immer gleich. Das ist wie bei Podcasts inzwischen. Bei Podcasts ist auch so Storytelling-Podcasts aus den USA oder jetzt aus Großbritannien, ich hab wieder einen gehört. Ich kann dir genau sagen, was in Folge 4 passiert. Es nervt so unfassbar. Na ja, also schaut alle Living Matchball Matchball Simeone. Nee, ist wirklich eine gute Doku. Und die Backcamp-Doku, die wird so sehr gehypt, da muss ich jetzt auch endlich mal reingehen. Aber die wollte ich mit jemandem zusammen gucken und wir finden keinen Termin, wie das, keine Ahnung, wie das zustande kommt. Könnte ja im Rasenfunk liegen. Ja stark, dann machen wir ein Rudelgucken über... Muss man das nicht heutzutage Watchparty nennen? Sagt ihr es mir.
Aber die Geschichte mit Simeone ist wirklich krass. Und ich fand es eigentlich ganz geil, dass Simeone in der Deko, in der Deko sag ich schon, nicht der Doku vorkam und sich dort gestellt hat, weil er kommt ja nicht gut weg dabei. Aber er steht zu sich und zu seiner Spielart von damals.
Also von daher, das war der Moment im Hause Hebel, wo ich fand, der Auftritt war echt sympathisch.
Ja, interessant, wie wir jetzt hier in den Themen gesprungen sind. Aber dann würde ich doch sagen, dann Uli, jetzt bist du eh schon hier gerade so mitten on fire, dann bring uns doch dein erstes Thema nahe. Wir wissen ja, dass du immer was Schweres und was Leichtes mitbringst. Wollen wir das Schwere vielleicht erst wegarbeiten? Was meinst du, wenn wir jetzt eh schon bei Simeone sind?
Das Schwere kriegt heute eine Wendung. Also ich mache mal Anti-Doku-Stil und versuche mich in einer Art Heldenreise. Zunächst hat es ganz viel Schwere bei Everton. Das ist das Thema, das ich mitgebracht habe. Haben am Samstag das Mercy Side Derby gegen Liverpool zwar verloren. Ich werde aber gleich darauf hinausgehen, dass sie grundsätzlich, glaube ich, okay sind in der Saison. Ich muss aber einmal anfangen bei was Grundlegendem, was über Everton schwebte die letzten drei Jahre, nicht gut geendet. Letztes Jahr sind sie eigentlich nur eines Tores wegen drin geblieben in der Liga. So ehrlich muss man sein. Sie haben in den letzten drei Jahren derart gemisswirtschaftet, dass sie jetzt, gestern Abend herausgekommen, ein unabhängiges Gremium der Premier League vorgeschlagen hat. Sie sollen mindestens zwölf Punkte Abzug bekommen, noch in der laufenden Saison, womöglich.
Aber sie haben doch nur sieben.
Ja, dann würden sie nicht okay sein, wenn das so sein würde. Und das hängt mit einer gewissen Tragik zusammen. Es gab in der letzten Saison im Frühjahr echt große Probleme mit Fans und dem aktuellen Board. Und vor allen Dingen dem German, der jetzt am Montag verstorben ist. Also alle wollten den unbedingt weghaben. Der ist am Montag sehr überraschend, wie ich finde, verschorben. Ich habe nichts von der Krankheit oder irgendwas gelesen. Und jetzt sortiert sich der Verein gerade neu und ist mittendrin in einem Takeover. Die 777-Group, Hertha, hat sich ein weiteres Asset dazugenommen und wird, so sind meine Informationen jetzt aus Everton, noch im Oktober übernehmen, wird aber dann erst in der Länderspielpause im November kommuniziert, so sagt man. Und dann wäre ein großes Kapitel bei Everton weg, was jetzt einfach mal den ganzen organisatorischen Kram betrifft. Es war eine absolute Chaos-Truppe in den letzten Jahren. Aber, und das ist jetzt der Swerve zum Positiven, dass sie sportlich richtige Schritte machen. Also zum ersten Mal in all den Jahren kann ich so was sagen, wie dass sie sich halbwegs vernünftig, die finanzielle Fairplay-Regeln, die ja dann schon drüberschweben, die finanzielle Lage macht es gar nicht so unbedingt möglich, dass sie etwas tun können. Aber sie haben sich erstmals halbwegs sinnvoll verstärkt oder ergänzt vor allen Dingen. Zweitens links verteidigt, endlich mal einen zweiten und sogar dritten Stürmer verpflichtet, nachdem Herbert Lohen einfach nicht gesund bleiben kann. Und haben sich einen guten Kopffallspieler in der Innenverteidigung dazugeholt, wieder zurückgeholt in Brantwick. Und Sean Deitsch hat vor der Länderspielpause z.B. einen höheren Expected Goals Wert gehabt als Manchester City. Wenn jetzt also die Chancenverwertung noch dazu käme, dann sind die gut. Die sind, glaube ich, gemessen an dem, was Deitsch will, noch nicht ganz so aggressiv im Pressing vorne, sind aber wahnsinnig gut im Umschalten nach hinten, sind super gut im tiefen Verteidigen, also etwas passiver. Das ist immer noch so das Problem, was ich habe, in der Premier League musst du aus meiner Sicht schon pressen, um eine Chance zu haben. Er schafft es aber mit Passivität auch ganz gut, kompakt zu stehen und das sieht nach einem wahnsinnig gut gecoachtem Team aus, mit Spielern, die überdurchschnittlich auf Bust und groß sind, also auf Füße stark sind. Deswegen denke ich, dass Everton in dieser Saison, also jetzt mal losgelöst vom Punkteabzug, den kann ich jetzt nicht mit einkalkulieren, aber wenn sie normal bleiben würden, haben die nicht im entferntesten mit dem Abstieg zu tun, dann gehen die Richtung 12, 13 würde ich sagen. Und das ist das Positivste, was ich über Everton seit Jahren erzählen kann.
Okay, aber ich muss nochmal ganz doof nachfragen. Tatsächlich, die 12 Punkte, gerade Financial Fair Play, ist das das Thema? Oder was haben sie gemacht?
Ja, genau. Sie haben jetzt in den letzten drei Jahren unterschiedliche Zahlen, aber bis zu 300 Millionen Verlust gemacht, weil, weiß man ja vielleicht, die haben sich einfach so ziemlich jeden einzelnen Namen, der es sich nicht zu schade war, nach Everton zu kommen, einfach unter den Nagel gerissen für viel zu viel Geld, inklusive Trainer und Abfindungen, also einfach völlig wahllos investiert, haben aber niemals, auch nur im entferntesten, irgendeinen Gewinn zu verzeichnen gehabt, im Sinne von zum Beispiel Spieleerlöse, das ist das, was man an erstes denkt, oder meinetwegen auch so was wie großartigen Anstieg im Merchandise oder Ticketing oder sowas. Der Kurs ist im Park ist relativ klein, dann haben sie ein neues Stadion noch, das 2024 kommen soll, also eingeweiht werden soll. Das ist ja auch das Positivste, was mir über die Amtszeit Mogiris sagen kann, ansonsten hat der einfach nur absolut viel Geld verbrannt.
Und für wie realistisch schätzt du das ein? Das ist natürlich jetzt extrem schwer, weil die Nachricht noch so frisch ist, also 12 Punkte, ich hab's ja gesagt, sie haben gerade erst 7 Punkte. Ich mein, der Abstiegskampf macht es möglich, dass sie dann immer noch mitten in der Verlosung wären mit minus 5 Punkten. Entschuldigung, hätten sie 9 Punkte Rückstand bzw. 10 Punkte Rückstand aufs Rettende Ufer. Das ginge sogar noch irgendwie. Und wir haben ja klar abgeschlagene Teams unten drin. Aber hättest du das für realistisch, diese drastische Strafe?
Also die 12 wäre mir ein bisschen zu hart. Ich würde tippen, das ist dann meistens in der Premier League erfahrungsgemäß. Wenn ein Vorschlag gemacht wird in Sachen Strafe, dann wird die Hälfte in etwa angenommen. Man würde sich auf 6 zusammenlaufen und vielleicht noch eine Art Transfer-Sperre ab. Weiß ich nicht. Sommer 24, das steht ja auch noch im Raum. Und ich würde sagen, meistens in der Premier League ist es so, dass es dann einfach eine Zusammensetzung ist aus den beiden Strafen. Was aber Everton natürlich schon auch hart treffen würde. Also, der Kader ist jetzt nicht besonders jung. Wenn man auch nicht transferieren dürfte. Schon gar nicht ablösefrei. Die Akademie geht so. Da kam jetzt nicht so richtig viel bei rum in den letzten Jahren. Und dann... Ja, bleiben die erst mal da, wo sie sind, nämlich am Rande. Aber das ist ja das Gute.
Wollen wir jetzt schon wettenabschließen, wie viel da da ist, dann vor der Transfer-Schwere noch zu Everton wechseln? Ich meine, ich weiß, dass das wahrscheinlich in der Premier League gar nicht irgendwie problematisiert wird, dass da ein Multi-Club-Oder-Ship-Ding sich einkauft. Weil man hat ja genügend andere Multi-Club-Oder. Und vor allem, man ist ja immer die Spitze der Pyramide. Wo ist das Problem eigentlich? Die besten Spieler fließen ja immer in die Premier League-Clubs dann rein. Aber das ist schon krass, was 777, also vor drei Jahren hätte ich noch gedacht, das ist ein Energy-Drink. Und welche Rolle die jetzt einfach im Fußball spielen?
Ja, das Ding ist ja, dass bei Everton so eine Situation vorherrscht, so ähnlich wie Newcastle. Es ist völlig egal, wer kommt. Hauptsache der Alte ist endlich weg, weil es einfach so... Es war so schlecht. Und ich will ihm gar nicht vorwerfen, dass er es nicht wollte. Der hat krass zum Angriff geblasen auf die Big Six. Und er hatte viel, viel Geld von sich selbst auch da rein investiert. Nur ist es halt vollkommen planlos. Und dann nutzt er nichts.
Ich glaube, die Lechzen dann auch wieder nach sportlichem Erfolg. Das hattest du mir auch mal im Zusammenhang mit Newcastle gesagt. Es ist ja auch nicht überall schiefgegangen mit 777. In Italien zum Beispiel. Klar, Genoa ist dann nach der Übernahme erst abgestiegen, aber ist jetzt wieder aufgestiegen und spielt sogar als Ausstärker gar nicht mehr so eine schlechte Rolle. Ja, und das ist jetzt ohne zu nah an der Premier League dran zu sein, das finde ich Everton schon auch ein Verein, wo ich Trikots sofort vor Augen habe. Also wäre ja auf jeden Fall irgendwie wünschenswert, dass die da irgendwie die Kurve bekommen. Aber Wetten abschließen ist nie eine gute Sache, Max.
Ja, das weiß ich natürlich. Wetten abschließen ist nie eine gute Sache. Du brauchst mir gerade eine Brücke, habe ich das Gefühl. Und über die, ach weißt du was, über die gehe ich jetzt auch einfach drüber. Also Everton, wir werden es genau verfolgen und wir merken uns aber alle, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für zukünftige 50 plus 1-Diskussionen. Auch das passiert, wenn man 50 plus 1 wegnimmt. Du kannst an einen Investor geraten, wo du dann so dankbar bist, dass irgendein Knochen zersägender Staat dir den Investor wegkauft, dass du dann dich vor Freude verkleidest, vor deinem Stadion ablichten lässt. Das kann auch die Folge von Investoren sein. Wollen wir das wirklich haben? Na gut, ich preache hier ja sowieso to the choir, aber das ist was anderes. Wetten, nie ein gutes Thema, hat Mario Rieker gesagt, außer in der Ligatur wird drüber gesprochen. Mario, wir kommen nicht dran vorbei. In der Serie A und im italienischen Fußball generell gab es einen großen Wett-Skandal, kann man denke ich schon so sagen. Diesmal betraf es direkt Spieler. Was müssen wir dazu wissen?
Ich glaube, man muss dazu wissen, dass man eventuell, falls ein Thema selber belastet ist und sich getriggert fühlt, sich dann nochmal Hilfe holen sollte, finde ich. Das sollte man wissen. Man muss dazu wissen, dass, ich glaube, das ist eine Sache, die man weiß, dass Fußballspieler sehr früh in jungen Jahren sehr viel Geld bekommen und manchmal vielleicht auch nicht wissen, was sie mit ihrer Zeit oder dem Druck anfangen können. In dem Fall sind welche dann dazu übergegangen, Druck in Suchtverlagerung umzuwandeln. Ich denke, jetzt ist es auch historisch gesehen nichts Neues, dass Profisportler wetten, viel wetten. Es gibt ja Geschichten von Nationalmannschaften, dass die unten in der Lobby stehen und für sich die 100-Euro-Scheine zustecken und auf den Aufzug drücken und sagen, welcher Aufzug als Erstes kommt. In dem Fall hat es aber tatsächlich in Italien noch mal eine neue Dimension genommen, da zwei junge Spieler vor allem über illegale Plattformen auf Fußballspiele, auf UEFA-Wettbewerbe gesetzt haben. In dem einen Fall Sandro Tonalis sogar auf die Spiele der eigenen Mannschaft. Immer unter der, auch wenn er gespielt hat, auch wenn er nicht gespielt hat, wohl nach seinen eigenen Aussagen. Ich habe keine Einsicht in die Ermittlungsakten, aber wohl immer nur auf einen Erfolg Milans. Das hat in dem Fall nicht seine Leistung beeinflusst, als dass er das Spiel verschoben hätte. Wobei ich mir auch vorstellen kann, dass dich hemmt, wenn du weißt, dass du 100k auf den Sieg hast. Dann steht es 1-1 und du musst in den letzten 5 Minuten noch richtig funktionieren. In einem anderen Fall ist es Niccolò Facioli von Juventus. Zu Nali, sogar schon zu Prescher-Zeiten war das wohl ein Fall. Und dann auch zu Milan-Zeiten, jetzt ist er ja bei Newcastle. Der soll Facioli bei einer Länderspielreise, die U21, damit angesteckt haben. Das ist aber jetzt auch wieder bestritten worden. Man begibt sich auch schon ein bisschen auf dünnes Eis, ohne dass die Ermittlungen vollumfänglich, da sie nicht komplett vollumfänglich aufgeklärt sind, da würde ich jetzt irgendwie kein Name-Cropping in die oder die Richtung betreiben. Klar ist auf jeden Fall, dass beide es zugegeben haben und dass beide auch über die Anwälte und Ärzte klargemacht haben, dass es sich bei ihnen um eine Spielsucht handelt. Beide haben jetzt eine Sperre erhalten. Facioli für sieben Monate und Tonali für zehn Monate. Finde ich ehrlicherweise bei Tonali, obdessen das er auf seine eigenen Spiele gesetzt hat, klingt das für mich im ersten Moment milde. Da würde mich dann gleich mal eure Einschätzung dazu interessieren. Aber beide haben eben vollumfänglich kooperiert. Beide haben die Auflage bekommen auch ein Gambling-Programm, also eine Spielsuchtprävention oder Suchtherapie zu machen, der sich Fatscholi zum Beispiel auch schon befindet. Alles wurde auch so ein bisschen losgestoßen durch einen, ich weiß ja, ich will eigentlich das Wort Journalist nicht für ihn benutzen, Fabrizio Corona, einen selber, der schon Promis, Fußballspieler, früher erpresst hat wegen Steuerhinterziehung. Insgesamt kommt er auf zehn Jahre Knast. Er war eigentlich Paparazzi. Mit den Fotos hat er teilweise auch so Leute wie Dressy G. Also auf jeden Fall ein wirklich guter Zeitgenosse. Der hat ganz viele Namen von Spielern getroppt. Er hat auch falsche Namen und Anschuldigungen erhoben. Aber er hat auch Treffer gelandet. Dazu gehören auch Fatsholi und Tonali dazu. Auch unter anderem Zanioli, der aber zum Beispiel nur in Anführungszeichen Casino-Spiele betrieben hat, aber auch über illegale Plattformen. Und so was so ein bisschen die ganze Dimension ausmacht, weil wenn wir gerade beim Thema Sucht sind, haben natürlich auch viele. Ich glaube, der Gedanke ist mir ehrlicherweise auch, so irgendwo hinten sagt der kleine Mann ja natürlich, sagt der Anwalt von denen jetzt, dass die spielsüchtig sind. Aber bei Niccolò Fatsholi ist es so, dass der wohl bis zu 3 Millionen Euro Schulden hat. Und es gab in der vergangenen Saison ein Spiel, da hat er einen Gegentor mit verschuldet, das ist später ausgewechselt worden und ist dann auf der Bank in Tränen ausgebrochen. Da dachte man damals, Uli, der ist halt sehr verbunden mit Juve und sehr Druck und jetzt hat er das Tor verschuldet. Ja, jetzt im Nachhinein hat er sich rausgestellt oder hat er gesagt, dass er da auf der Bank saß und an die 3 Millionen Euro gedacht hat. Also der hat sich auch Geld bei Mitspielern, bei Beratern von Mitspielern geliehen. Und das spricht dafür tatsächlich, finde ich, dass da durchaus was dran ist. Denn ein Thema versucht es ja, dass man dann nicht aufhören kann. Und wenn du da dann schon mal in so einer Spirale drin bist, dann ist das glaube ich in einem Business, was sonst auch schon viel Druck mitbringt für so einen jungen Kopf eines Heranwachsenden, was er ja immer noch ist, irgendwie mit Anfang 20, glaube ich, ein ganz schöner Brainfuck, auf jeden Fall. Und den beiden, in erster Linie finde ich persönlich nur zu wünschen, dass sie jetzt damit, dass sie dann an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen sind, da ihnen dann doch noch auch eine Zukunft im Profifußball bevorsteht und die das irgendwie gut aufarbeiten. Auf der anderen Seite hängt natürlich ein riesen Ratenschwanz dran für die Vereine. Uli im Newcastle, ich glaube, die sind halt nicht so amused. Und es spricht natürlich auch einiges dafür, dass bei Milan das eventuell schon Leute wussten, wenn es auch schon bei Brescia davor der Fall war. Jetzt will Newcastle Milan verklagen. Ich bin kein Jurist. Andererseits, das musst du denen jetzt auch erstmal beweisen, dass die das wussten, bevor sie ihn verkauft haben. Bei Fadjoli ist es so, da steht Juve, der Verein voll hinter ihm. Der darf weiter mit trainieren, der bekommt sogar weiterhin sein Gehalt. Und die 7 Monate Sperre würde auslaufen bei ihm zum letzten Spieltag der jetzigen Saison. Und er könnte dann da nochmal wieder zurückkommen. Bei Tonali sind es 10 Monate. Und der wird damit die Europameisterschaft verpassen.
An was ich gedacht habe, als ich das gelesen habe, jetzt verstehe ich, warum Milan den so recht widerstandslos hat gehen lassen. Weil es hat mich so gewundert, dass man den A überhaupt gehen lässt und B, dass das alles so schnell ging.
Ja, vor allem, und er ist ja auch ein großer, das hat er immer gesagt, und er ist ja ein riesengroßer Milan-Fan. Also wenn die ihm gesagt haben, Junge, wäre ganz geil, wenn du jetzt gehst, dann kriegen wir noch Geld für dich. Und du kannst, wenn Newcastle dich dann nicht mehr haben will, kannst du in 14 Monaten wiederkommen, wenn du möchtest. Ja, klar, das ist jetzt natürlich alles viel Spekulation, was ja auch in den letzten Wochen um viele Namen war, viel Spekulation mit dabei. Krasses Thema auf jeden Fall. Es hat in Italien natürlich auch wieder einen Riesenschlag getan. Und es sorgt auch wieder ein wenig dafür, im Narrativ, wenn man sich ab und an auf der, sagen wir jetzt, nicht der ganz investigativen deutschen Presse annähert, dann werden da natürlich auch wieder viele Schubladen von Südeuropäern aufgemacht.
Ach so, ach krass.
Aber die machen wir einfach direkt hier zu. Also ich glaube nicht, dass nur in Italien Fußballspieler Probleme haben.
Genau, das ist ja genau der Punkt.
Auf dem Hinblick gibt es so ein Riesenproblem. Didi Hamann ganz früher war sehr geisteskrank. Da gibt es ja Dunkelziffern, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Aber Alvin Toney ist ja gerade noch mitten in einer Sperre. Kieran Trippier war der Pionier, der auch Mannschaftskollege ist von Tonali. Und es gibt auch in England schon wieder erste Berichte darüber, dass es noch einige viele gibt, deren Namen einfach nur noch nicht bekannt sind. Und man hoffte halt mit der extremeren Sperre gegen Toney, dass man ein wenig abgeschreckt hat. Aber nein, das ist ja der Punkt. Wir reden ja hier von kranken Menschen. Ich tue mich auch. Letztlich müsste man das ja einmal laut diskutieren, weil auf der einen Seite sind die krank und ich habe kein Verständnis in dem Sinne dafür, weil ich es halt nicht verstehe, weil ich nicht krank bin. Aber durchaus Mitgefühl und versucht das dann auch in eine Richtung zu drehen, dass man sagt, die können nichts dafür. Auf der anderen Seite müssen wir natürlich den Sport mit einem, was wir haben, beschützen. Weil wenn einer auf eigene Spiele und vielleicht sogar Niederlagen wettet, das ist ja leichter zu beeinflussen, dann öffnen wir Dinge, die wir unbedingt nicht öffnen wollen. Deswegen muss die Strafe auch so hart sein. Du hast ja vorher gesagt, 10 Monate. Also ich habe jetzt nur gelesen, ich weiß aber nicht, ob das stimmt. Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung von der Rechtsprechung. Und das liegt ja dann auch nochmal im jeweiligen Erfüllungsland sozusagen. Oder wenn man es auf die Fußballgerichtsbarkeit anwendet, dazu habe ich es gelesen, sind sogar bis zu 3 Jahre vorgesehen für die Vergehen. Und dann finde ich es wiederum, ist es ja fast schon anständig.
Ich meine, 3 Jahre würde das Karriereende bedeuten. Christian Bern hat auch gesagt, dass es zwischen 3 und 6 Jahre angesetzt wird. Gerade auch, wenn dann eigene Spiele beeinflusst werden, was sozusagen jetzt negiert wurde, da er womöglich nur auf Siege im Milan gesetzt hat. Aber im Vergleich zu 3 bzw. 6 Jahre fühlen sich die 10 Monate wenig an. Aber ich bin voll bei dir, weil das Argument kommt ja auch oft, ein Mannschaftssportler, aber auf der Ebene, wir wissen auch alle, das ist jetzt auch eine Platitüde, aber es ist halt ein Fehlersport. Also ich glaube, wenn du ein Champions-League-Spiel einnimmst, der nicht richtig mitten macht, dann beeinflusst das sehr, sehr viel.
Gleichzeitig ist es aber auch ein bisschen scheinheilig vom Fußball. Ich finde, als Vergleichsliga kann man ganz gut die NFL nehmen. Die NFL ist so rigide, dass wenn du innerhalb von Club-Facilities, also Gebäuden, auf andere Sportarten wettest, dann wirst du da für die komplette Saison einfach gesperrt. Da gibt es richtig drakronische Maßnahmen. Aber warum macht die NFL das? Weil sie eben im Sportwettenbereich extrem viel Geld verdient, das sehr wichtig für sie ist und sie deswegen quasi jeden Eindruck vermeiden will, dass da irgendwas auch nur ganz leicht beeinflusst wird. Das führt zu drakronischen Maßnahmen, führt es aber dazu, dass die jungen NFL-Spieler nicht mehr machen. Nee, jedes Jahr hast du neue Strafen. Und im Fußball ist es ja auch so, der Fußball nimmt wahnsinnig viel Geld von Sportwetten-Anbietern. Wenn du spielsüchtig bist, ist es eigentlich nicht möglich, Fußball zu konsumieren, ohne die ganze Zeit wieder getriggert zu werden an deine alte Sucht. Da gibt es zum Beispiel den Sportwetten-Glücklich-Podcast. Ich muss nochmal gerade nachgucken, wie er genau heißt. Gibt es schon seit ganz, ganz vielen Jahren. Die berichten da zum Beispiel drüber. Und ich habe auch schon seit Ewigkeiten das Tribüngespräch eigentlich so im Hinterkopf. Und auf der einen Seite nimmst du aus diesem Ecke sehr, sehr viel Geld. Das ist der wichtigste Sponsoring-Partner im Fußball weltweit. Und du machst das eigentlich Spielsüchtigen extrem schwer überall an jeder Ecke. Denn du kannst eigentlich keinen Fußball mehr konsumieren, wenn du ein solches Problem oder diese Krankheit hast. Und dann wiederum bist du aber dann sehr drakonisch, wenn es dann eigene Spieler betrifft. Also das ist auch extrem... Da ist wieder so eine Ambivalenz drin, die schwer auszuhalten ist, wo man auch eigentlich innerhalb von ein paar Minuten das gar nicht ausdiskutieren kann. Aber das steckt eben auch in diesen Fällen drin und auch in diesen Strafen drin. Selbst wenn jetzt jemand dann für drei Jahre oder sechs Jahre gesperrt wird und damit de facto die Karriere beendet ist, müsste man ja trotzdem die Frage stellen, wenn es euch denn so wichtig ist, dieses Thema, warum macht ihr denn an der anderen Stelle immer nur so Symbolismus? Also dass es dann hin und wieder mal auch den Hinweis darauf gibt, hey, wenn du Spielsuchtprobleme hast, dann wende dich doch bitte hier hin und übrigens jetzt noch mal Kohle ersetzen auf das Topspiel des Abends.
Also die HörerInnen können ja mal den, vielleicht jetzt einmal kurz anhalten und dann einen neuen Tab Liga Serie A tim.com aufmachen, die Homepage Serie A. Und dann könnt ihr mal gucken, was das erste ist, bevor man überhaupt erst auf die Homepage kommen kann.
Ja, in Spanien haben sie es ja übrigens so gemacht, ich glaube, letztes Jahr war das, dass sie Wettanbietern verboten haben, um Trikotsponsor zu sein und so weiter. Real Madrid war ja von Badwin Win oder Bwin, oder wie es auch meistens heißt, da haben sie viel Geld bekommen, andere Vereine auch. Das haben sie zumindest im Fußball verboten. Das war auch eine große Sache, Wettan hier in Spanien ist nach wie vor natürlich möglich, aber es wird nicht mehr, also die direkte Werbung ist ziemlich verboten, auch im Fernsehen ist das eigentlich kaum mehr. Und ja, ich denke, die haben da, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Schritt in die Richtung gemacht, weil es tatsächlich so ist, dass du dich mit Leuten teilweise unterhältst und bei vielen triggert das direkt die Wette. Also nicht so, wie siehst du das Spiel, wie kann es ausgehen, ja, da musst du da wetten. Ich kann mich erinnern, vor zwei Jahren bin ich in Berlin gewesen, bin zum Champions League Final gefahren im Taxi, das war Liverpool gegen Tottenham und dann so, ja fahr schnell, ich muss zum Anschluss kommen und bla. Und dann haben wir halt über das Champions League Finale gesprochen und er hat mir eigentlich nur seine ganzen Wettquoten und alles erzählt. Konnte mir aber, glaube ich, kein Spiel, also übertrieben, aber wusste nicht viel zum Spiel an sich, aber wusste alle Wettquoten und was man alles machen muss und so weiter. Das ist schon ein Thema, das nicht ohne ist.
Also ich kann nur aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, ich habe seit 14 Monaten keine Sportwette mehr gemacht und das war eine der besten Entscheidungen in den letzten paar Jahren in meinem Leben und jeder, der das Gefühl hat, dass er das vielleicht mal ausprobieren sollte, dem kann ich nur dazu raten, wenn man das mehrmals die Woche macht oder so und man mit den Gedanken an sowas aufsteht zum Beispiel, dann ist es kompliziert, sich selbst sperren zu lassen, aber wenn man es erstmal gemacht hat, ist es kompliziert. Dann habe ich dann in den ersten zwei Wochen versucht, das wieder aufzuheben. Das funktioniert sehr wenig und dann lässt dann das irgendwann nach, nach ein, zwei Wochen und dann fühlt sich es irgendwann sehr gut an und man kann. Und das ist jetzt natürlich das Lustige, weil ich gesagt habe, du wirst getriggert und so. Ich arbeite auch in der Sache, ich habe genug Trigger-Punkte jede Woche, jeden Punkt gehabt und irgendwann diese Trigger dann nicht mehr zu haben, das fühlt sich sehr gut an so und ich kann deswegen, wie Uli das gesagt hat, man kann für bestimmte, ich habe für andere Sachen dann auch Empathie, aber man kann es dann nicht selber nicht verstehen, aber wenn man selber das auch noch nachempfinden kann, glaube ich. Und der ist ja auch, der geht jeden Tag auf den Trainingsplatz und in der Kabine wird nur drüber geredet, über andere Spiele und der fährt nach Hause wieder, Handy raus, wettet darauf und wenn der dann anfängt noch in der Kabine vorm Spiel gegen Juve eventuell drauf zu setzen, dass wir heute zwei Tore schießen oder so. Das ist ja unvorstellbar, was der da in seinem jungen Kopf veranstaltet haben muss in den letzten Jahren.
Aber absolut. Also glücklich süchtig ist der Podcast. Den möchte ich euch wirklich sehr empfehlen. Den habe ich damals, als die losgestartet sind, habe ich da öfter rein gehört und die sind jetzt eben schon seit vielen Jahren mit dabei. Und es ist ein riesiges Thema. Ich habe auch irgendwie das Gefühl, es wird nicht das letzte Mal sein, dass wir hier drüber sprechen. Und es ist aber verrückt, wie welche Narrative da gestrickt werden. Es gibt jetzt bei der NFL in dieser Saison, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal einen Werbespot, der eben zwischen den, in den vielen Werbeunterbrechungen zwischen den Spielzügen kommt, wo es darum geht, um die Garbage Time. Das ist quasi, wenn das Spiel eigentlich entschieden ist und dann hinten raus dann das Stadion schon leer wird und da wird damit gewettet, hey, Garbage Time, du bist der Einzige, der noch richtig Bock darauf hat, weil du hast jetzt noch eine Wette abgeschlossen und das ist richtig spannend, obwohl es die Garbage Time ist, wo ich mir auch so gedacht habe, meine Güte, krass, also einfach nur krass, wie man die Leute.
Aber sagen wir ehrlich, es ist doch verwundernswert, dass es in der Fußballberichterstattung noch nicht das Einpflegen von Wettquoten gibt, das der Kommentator vorzulesen hat. Es gibt jetzt was weiß ich, 1,12 auf, ich kenne mich da 0,0 aus, ist überhaupt nicht mein Thema, aber aus meiner Sicht, ich dachte, dass wir nicht 2024 erreichen, ehe das passiert.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich letztens auch darüber Gedanken gemacht, weil es gibt ja auch, die meisten Fernsehanstalten haben ja inzwischen auch selber eine Plattform, das mal so auszudrücken. Ich glaube, das hat in Deutschland tatsächlich was mit Geld im Recht zu tun, weil wenn, ich glaube, es gibt ja schon manchmal, wenn der Bild schon ein bisschen kleiner wird und dann eine Werbung reinkommt und da müssen Hinweise draufstehen. Also sozusagen, wenn du jetzt sozusagen dir gesagt werden würdest, Uli, sag mal, in den letzten 15 Minuten, wenn ein Tor fällt, kriegst du noch die Quote dafür, dann müsste da noch ein Hinweis darauf kommen, dass du das gesüchtlich machen kannst. Deswegen kannst du das, glaube ich, nicht redaktionell in dem Sinne einbinden.
Andersherum, Wettanbieter leisten sich ja zum Beispiel schon Audio-Streams, damit du zumindest unterstützen kannst, das Spiel geht in die Richtung, also setz mal da drauf.
Ja, und es gibt ja auch Wettanbieter, die viel da auch live streamen. Also zum Beispiel Serie B habe ich ganz lange, weiß ich auch bei Marius, zum Beispiel, wenn der Palmer guckt, gibt es einen Wettanbieter, bei dem kannst du umsonst Fußball gucken, wenn du ein bisschen Geld auf dem Konto hast. Und dann guckst du Fußball und nebenher sind da die Quoten.
Ja, und das ist ja auch das Geschäftsmodell von manchen Lizenzinhabern, die ihre Lizenzrechte nicht finanziert bekommen. Und das, also, und zwar sämtliche, also alle Lizenzinhaber, die das haben. Also da muss man jetzt gar nicht mit dem Finger auf jemanden zeigen. Ich habe jetzt nur ganz kurz das Dokument aufgemacht, was ich glaube ich im Jahr 2015 zum Thema Sportwetten angefangen habe zu pflegen. Also ich bin schon länger da dran. Ich nenne nur ein paar Zahlen und dann glaube ich können wir zum nächsten Thema gehen, aber nur damit klar ist, auch warum dann in Deutschland politisch nichts dagegen gemacht wird, weil damit sehr, sehr viel Geld verdient wird. Und Punkt 2 ist, es gibt einen riesigen Graubereich, in dem illegal gewettet wird und in den würden auch ganz viele abwandern. Das will der Staat auch nicht. 2016, also man sieht, das sind jetzt alte Zahlen, da wurde eine Billion Euro Umsatz generiert, 70 Prozent mit Fußball weltweit. In Deutschland wurden 2018 9 Milliarden Euro auf Sportereignisse gewettet und ich habe hier noch Zahlen zur Bundesliga. Auf einem Bundesligaspiel werden geschätzt etwa 70 Millionen Euro pro Partie gewettet. In der 2. Liga sind es immer noch 20 Millionen Euro. Und zwar egal, ob Hoffenheim, Augsburg, Bayern oder Dortmund. Also das sind die Dimensionen, über die wir sprechen und das sind alles noch alte Zahlen. Wenn ich die jetzt erneuen würde, sind die sehr wahrscheinlich gestiegen. Das ist quasi die Größe dieses Marktes und damit auch die potenzielle Größe des Problems. Denn logischerweise gibt es einen fixen Prozentsatz an Menschen, die sind spielsüchtig. Das ist einfach nachgewiesen, dass es da eben eine Neigung zu gibt und die sind da mittendrin in diesen mehreren Milliarden, die da gesetzt werden. Aber gut, das Tribüngespräch, es wird irgendwann kommen. Es haben dann irgendwann andere Medien angefangen zu berichten. Da dachte ich, vielleicht muss ich es nicht mehr machen. Und hört euch glücklich süchtig an. Das war jetzt ein langer Zwischenpart. Ich habe total vergessen, wer jetzt dran wäre.
Wir machen mal wieder was Positives, oder? Ja, was Positives. Meine Lieblinge, meine Basken von Athletic Bilbao, die haben einen relativ ordentlichen Saisonstart hinter sich, nachdem es letztes Jahr nicht so gut lief. Und da drin Ernesto Valverde. Und ja, schon spekuliert worden ist, ob er vielleicht den Verein wieder verlassen muss. Und dieses Jahr haben sie sich wieder sehr gut gefangen. Und kurioserweise stellen sie auch, glaube ich, nicht so viele Nationalspieler wie selten zuvor oder wie fast nie. Was ja eigentlich gegen die Vereinsphilosophie fast schon geht. Wobei das immer auch ein bisschen entspannter geworden ist. Ja, und wir haben mal mit Unai Simón, den spanischen Nationaltorhüter. Man hat mit Nico Williams einen Flügelstürmer, der im Moment in Wunden vieler großer Vereine ist, auch in der Premier League. Real Madrid soll angeblich auch Interesse haben, Barca auch. Der ist erst 21 und ja, der ist eigentlich in der Nationalmannschaft eigentlich schon, jetzt würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, eine fixe Größe, aber er ist auf jeden Fall jedes Mal dabei. Dann gibt es einen offensiven Mittelfeldspieler mit Ojan Sanced, der ist auch erst 23. Der hat jetzt seinen Debüt gefahren in den vergangenen Spielen und dort auch gleich ein Tor geschossen. Mit Paredes gibt es nur 21 Nationalspieler. Spaniens machen einen ganz guten Job. Am Wochenende haben wir knapp 1-0 bei Barcelona verloren. Hätten dort aber gut und gerne auch mehr mitnehmen können, ist ein bisschen unglücklich verlaufen für die Basken. Wir hatten auch gute Chancen durch Williams. Ich glaube, wir sind im Moment in der 6. Wir haben in dem Fall alles richtig gemacht am Trainer, Walwerde festzuhalten, der eigentlich schon fast gehen sollte.
Aber der ist wieder zurück auf alten Höhen. Er kam damals von Athletik-Bebau zu Barca. Die Barca-Zeit haben wir alle besser mitbekommen. Jetzt aktuell ist man wieder so, dass man den alten Walwerde hat.
Er ist ja auch eine Vereinslegende, obwohl er kein Basketballer ist. Sein Spielstil war natürlich auch kritisiert worden. Im letzten Jahr gab es natürlich auch ein paar Leistungsschwankungen. Zum Beispiel auch bei Nico Williams. Wobei man das in einem 20-Jährigen zugestehen sollte. Im Mittelfeld hat er viel ausprobiert. Eine interessante Personalie, die ich noch finde, ist vielleicht Ander Herrera. Der war ja auch mal bei Paris Saint-Germain und Manchester United. Seine große Phase ist natürlich vorbei. Im Moment ist er leider auch viel verletzt. Jetzt hat er sich gerade am letzten Spieltag beim Warmwachen nochmal verletzt. Da war er nämlich gerade wieder in einer aufkommenden Form und hat eigentlich fast wieder Stamm gespielt. Der hat natürlich schon nochmal das Auge für den letzten Pass oder die Spielvision, die vielleicht andere nicht haben. Der hat den Basken auch sehr gut getan. Ich hoffe, es ist jetzt eine leichte Muskelverletzung und er kann wieder zurückkommen. Denn im Mittelfeld sind sie ein bisschen knapper besetzt, sage ich jetzt mal von der Qualität her. Aber vorne und hinten ist das sehr ordentlich im Moment. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass die es dieses Jahr wieder ins internationale Geschäft schaffen.
Diese Baskischen Vereine, ich verstehe schon, warum das deine Lieblingsvereine sind. Das ist so verrückt, dass die das immer wieder schaffen. Und dass da jetzt auch schon wieder so viele Nationalspieler rumlaufen und dieser Mix an jungen und alten Spielen ist bei Bilbao gerade wirklich geil. Ich habe neulich ein Spiel von denen drüber gesappt und mir kurz den Kader aufgemacht, der da auf dem Feld stand. Da dachte ich mir auch, das ist ja sauwitzig. Da laufen einfach die jungen, die jungen Next Big Things laufen da rum neben den alten, die eben sagen, okay Junge, aber also Grätsch muss da auch hin und wieder. Ich zeig's dir mal kurz, hier hast du zugeguckt.
Ja, das ist echt cool. Im Falle von Bilbao, die anderen Vereine, kaufen ja auch Spieler aus den Rest Spaniens oder internationalen Spielen ein. Aber du hast da wirklich ein kleines Land, eigentlich nur, und eine geringe Spielerauswahl, aber halt eine sehr gute Jugendarbeit. Es ist einfach nach wie vor eine der schönsten Philosophien, die es im Fußball gibt, wie ich finde. Ich freue mich immer, wenn es bei denen läuft.
Aber geht es in der Jugendarbeit auch ums Gewinnen? Das ist ja das Wichtigste. Bekommen da die Kinder beigebracht zu gewinnen, Fabian?
Der Ball wird natürlich erstmal weggenommen. Es geht erstmal nur um taktische Disziplin. Ich kann es dir nicht genau sagen. Natürlich ist es auch so, dass sie von anderen baskischen Vereinen die Jugendtalente wegholen. Die bilden jetzt nicht alle selber aus. Aber es wird halt so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl geschaffen und es wird schon versucht, eine Philosophie irgendwo auch beizubehalten, die dann auch in die erste Mannschaft, in die zweite Mannschaft übergenommen wird.
Die bilden auch Trainer aus ohne Ende. Du kannst es besser aussprechen, Giputskoa, oder wie das da heißt? Ateta kommt daher, Alonso, die übrigens wöchentlich miteinander telefonieren, habe ich mir jetzt sagen lassen. Sie sind sehr, sehr gut miteinander, haben ja auch einen ähnlichen Stil. Dann ist da der von, wie heißt der, ich habe immer das Gefühl, Batman, der von Real Zasidat San Sebastian ist auch hier. Denke immer an Batman, Aguasil. Ich denke immer an den Bösewicht von Batman, wenn ich den Namen höre. Und Una Emery auch, ne?
Ja, genau. Die haben schon eine gute Schmiede. Auch bei San Sebastian machen sie verdammt gute Arbeiten. Arteta und Xavi Alonso haben die nicht mal zusammengespielt.
Daher kommt wohl bis heute die Freundschaft, die sie noch mal intensiviert hat.
Die werden sich auch noch mal sehen bei irgendwelchen wichtigen Spielen, in irgendwelchen wichtigen Finalen, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Das glaube ich allerdings auch. Aber glaubt ihr, ist das dann so, wie wenn man einen Freund einmal die Woche anruft oder meinte, die haben vielleicht einen Schuh fix, wo sie sich immer, Donnerstag 9 Uhr, das ist jetzt ein fiktives Beispiel, dass die sich dann immer treffen. Dann sprechen sie mit dem Gewinnen von Jugendmannschaften. Ich schaffe heute aber nur 15 nach, weil die Kinder wollten heute die Jacke selber anziehen.
Also geplante Telefonate bei Spanien kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen. Das sind doch schon wieder Klischees hier. Das läuft schon südländisch ab. Da wird erst mal eine Viertelstunde, halbe Stunde gequatscht, wie geht es dir, wie geht es der Family und bla, bla, bla.
Fabian, wir haben uns um 8.59 Uhr getroffen. Wann habe ich mit der Sendung begonnen? 9.18 Uhr oder was?
Das ist sehr spanisch.
Das ist zum ersten Mal, dass ich als Südländer bezeichnet werde in irgendetwas. Also, Athletik Bebau, Platz 6, 17 Punkte. Da sieht es gerade sehr, sehr gut aus. Jetzt wollen wir nochmal in die Serie A hüpfen. Diesmal wird es ein bisschen kürzer. Das Thema wird auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen leichter. Mario?
Ja, über Juve zu sprechen, ist nie richtig leicht. Es ist positiv, aber auch nicht so richtig. Also, Juve ist wieder da. Juve ist wieder da. Spielt jetzt auch seit paar Spieltagen, nachdem man an den ersten drei Spieltagen mit Vlaović, Keza und war auch richtig tempo drin. Jetzt sind sie wieder da, weil sie Juve Fußball spielen. Und unter anderem dann 1-0 bei Milan gewonnen haben am vergangenen Wochenende. Und stehen auf Platz drei, haben erst ein Spiel verloren. Und das sieht wieder vor allem nach einer Mannschaft aus. Sie haben auch wieder Spiele, mit denen sich die Tifosi identifizieren, welche, die sich selber mit dem Verein sehr identifizieren. Zum Beispiel Gatti hinten, junger Verteidiger. Der ist dann zuletzt im Derby gegen Torino sein erstes Tor geschossen hat und völlig ausgeflippt ist. Also es wächst wieder was. Und es wächst wieder so ein Selbstverständnis. Fino Anafine, das ist das italienische Mir San Mier. Und sollten alle, auch wenn Allegri nach der Leistung gegen Milan gesagt hat, wir sind kein Scudetto-Kandidat, das ist dann wiederum nicht so das Selbstverständnis von früher, aber er ist schon auch gut darin, das Ganze vom Erwartungsmanagement her zu moderieren. Aber die anderen Vereine da oben sollten sich diese Saison in Acht nehmen, glaube ich. Denn es fehlt die Doppelbelastung. Sie können nur die Liga spielen. Und sie haben Milan jetzt geschlagen, obwohl Keza und Vlaović nicht mit dabei waren von Anfang an. Wenn da der Kader komplett jetzt auch in der Breite, den sie haben, vom körperlichen her fit bleibt, dann ist das durchaus eine Mannschaft, die in der Lage ist, auch irgendwie 12 Spiele in Folge 1 zu 0 zu gewinnen.
Aber das heißt quasi, weil du gesagt hast, es fällt ja nie so leicht, dann über Juve zu sprechen. Das liegt dann quasi an der Art und Weise, wie gespielt wird.
Ja, also das gegen Milan war taktisch einfach klug, muss man einfach sagen. Und es war von Stefano Pioli, der jetzt auch, Uli hat es gestern beobachtet, auch schon im nächsten Topspiel wieder bewiesen hat, dass er irgendwie in den Topspielen nicht den richtigen Dreh findet. Klar, das war zu Hause gegen Juve, da wollte man sie schon auch mit dem Publikum rücken, hoch anlaufen und da sind sie eiskalt auch rausgenommen worden von Juve aus dem Spiel. Aber zum Beispiel die Woche davor, dass Turina Derby, dass ich begleiten durfte mit Christian, wo man sich dann irgendwie auf einen Kampf und zumindest irgendwie hohes Tempo und Derby-Atmosphäre freut. Also da wie die Dementoren alle Spielfreude aus dem Spiel rausgesaugt und dann zynisch Juve-like 1-0, dann ist 2-0 irgendwann nachgelegt und dann ist da einfach nichts mehr passiert. Deswegen fällt das oft, finde ich. Wer richtig gute Fußballspiele sehen möchte, der muss nicht zu Juve gehen. Aber das war auch in der Vergangenheit noch nie ihr Anspruch und ehrlicherweise auch von vielen eigenen Fans ist das nicht der Anspruch. Es geht halt ums Gewinnen.
Das sagen vielleicht auch die Kommentatoren sich. Da ist es natürlich bitter, wenn zu einem Spiel die komplette Energie...
Man kann es aber die ganze Zeit natürlich über die Spannung ziehen. Das ist ja immer das. Juve führt ja nie. Die machen es nie 4-0 und lassen es dann runterlaufen. Aber die spielen auch oft nach einem 1-0, als würden sie 4-0 führen. Und dann wird das nach Hause verwaltet.
Und diejenigen, die die Nebenbemerkung nicht verstanden haben, Milan hat 0-3 bei PSG verloren in der Champions League. Das muss man dazu noch wissen. Und so arg viele Chancen gab es da nicht, die ich da in der Zusammenfassung gesehen hätte für Milan. Das war dann schon auch von der Spielweise her so deutlich. Dann, Uli, wollen wir nochmal in die Premier League reinschauen. Das leichte Thema wartet auf uns. Da freue ich mich schon die ganze Zeit drauf.
Es bleibt aber grundsätzlich immer vom Ansatz her das Gleiche. Aston Villa ist auch mal vor ein paar Jahren angetreten, um es den Big Six möglichst schwer zu machen, eine Sechser-Gruppe zu bleiben. Dann gab es den Zwerf, dass der Kollege Gerard das Ganze beinahe in den Sand gesetzt hätte. Jetzt ist Una Emery da seit einem guten Jahr. Im November wird es ein Jahr. Direkt nach der WM-Jahr angefangen. Seitdem geht es in die komplett richtige Richtung. Es ist erstaunlich, dass sie im Moment die zweitbeste Offensive der Liga stellen. Sie haben immer Match-Glück. Ich glaube, dass Una Emery kennt, dass das kein Glück ist, sondern dass das erzwungen ist. Das ist eine der positiven Stories der Saison. Ich hätte es so nicht gedacht. Ich habe geglaubt, dass sie mit den Transfers, die sie gemacht haben, ein paar mehr Probleme kriegen. Im Bereich der Flag-Mass. Bis dato findet er gegen die großen Teams einfach wahnsinnig clevere Matchpläne. Er ist ein super Underdog-Trainer. In den Spielen gegen die Teams, die noch talentlevelmäßig über ihnen stehen, haben sie mehr Schwierigkeiten. Das war so zu erwarten. Sie sind vom Kader her nicht besser als 5 oder 6, sondern sie sind wahrscheinlich in den Dunstkreis danach. Deshalb ist das echt ein sehr positives Ding. Jeden einzelnen Spieler, das kennt man ja auch von Emery, spielt im Grunde mit derselben Anfangsformation Woche für Woche, wenn er nicht wechseln muss. Aber von diesen Spielern hat er jeden einzelnen Spielern mindestens eine Kaste nach oben wandern lassen in Sachen Konstanz und grundsätzliches Leistungsvermögen.
Das klingt wirklich sehr gut. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, warum du bei Diaby ein Fleck mal ausgemacht hast. Das ist vielleicht eine Arbeit gegen den Ball, manchmal so ein bisschen.
Ja, da gab es schon Szenen, wo er sich so positioniert, dass ich gedacht hab, ich tu mal so, als würde ich jetzt pressen und warte einfach nur schon mal aufs Mögliche umschalten. Da hab ich schon gedacht, dass die vielleicht zusammenrumpeln könnten. Leon Bailey und so auch.
Ja, okay, okay, das stimmt schon. Manchmal hat Diaby schon so getan, als ob sein Deckungsschatten noch breiter wäre. Was denn? Ich hab den doch abgedeckt. Huch, jetzt kam der Pass zu ihm. Das kann nicht mein Fehler. Ja, okay, das stimmt schon. Aber ist es denn auch dann gut anzusehen, der Fußball?
Nö, aber die Einzelaktionen, das muss man schon sagen, das ist jetzt strukturell nicht der Wahnsinn. Das ist der Klassiker, die warten halt, pressen ab der eigenen Hälfte. Wenn man viel Premier League guckt, dann langweilt einem das schon zu Tode, weil man halt schon will, dass die auch vorne drauflaufen. Die großen oder die richtig guten Teams, die machen das nicht mal mehr Mann gegen Mann, sondern die pressen schon sozusagen gegen den Raum. Das ist bei denen vergleichsweise langweilig. Es rührt sich erst mal wenig. Und dann geht es halt recht direkt nach vorne, nach Balleroberung. Das funktioniert dann attraktivitätsmäßig über das Tempo, das einfach da ist in dem Kader. Und über die zum Teil aber auch Raffinesse in einem völlig beeindruckenden Mittelfeld. Also was da für einen Namen herumschwirren ist, ist echt erstaunlich für ein Team, das den Anspruch hat, obere Mitte zu enden in der Premier League. Und darüber kommt dann so eine gewisse Attraktivität. Aber das Spiel oder die Spielanlage an sich, da kannst du jetzt nicht die Stadien voll mitmachen.
Okay, ich sehe schon. Und man hat halt mit Oli Wattgens jemanden, fünf Tore, fünf Vorlagen in neuen Premier League Spielen. Läuft bei ihm, würde ich sagen.
Er ist echt ein fantastischer Stürmer. Ich habe selten einen gesehen, der ist ganz unten gekommen, vom Level her, über Exeter, Vierte Liga und so. Davor noch Non-League gespielt. Gar nicht so ein Jugendleistungszentrum-Mann, sondern hochgekommen, der hat so einen natürlichen Instinkt.
Ah, der Kevin Behrens, der Premier League. Ich habe noch keinen Bundesliga-Vergleich gemacht, das ist mir gerade angefallen.
Sehr gut.
Okay, sehr gut, schön. Und damit habe ich doch eigentlich auch schon die Brücke gebaut ins letzte Segment. Wir wollen noch unsere Awards vergeben. Da sind wir ja dann schon bei MVP, Anzang Hero und Moment des Spieltags. Mario, du darfst mal loslegen. Wer ist denn dein MVP aktuell?
Aktuell würde ich sagen, ist es Simone Insagi. Sie ist Trainer von Inter Mailand. Warum? Mailand spielt gerade so überzeugend, so abgeklärt. Aber auch ansehnlichen Fußball geht kaum was an denen vorbei, glaube ich, in der Serie A. Und auch in der Champions League wirkt es super stabil. Also sind sie auch schon eigentlich kurz davor, sich für die K.O.-Phase zu qualifizieren. Und es war ja schon auch ein Trainer, glaube ich, den ich immer so gesagt habe, muss ich noch beweisen. Und letztes Jahr Champions League-Finale da auf Augenhöhe. Und jetzt so die Transition in die neue Saison, wo man sich auch gedacht hat, kann Inter das bestätigen. Gab ja auch irgendwie das ein oder andere Mal ein bisschen Unruhe mit Lukaku, das alles und so. Aber wie die jetzt auch in die Saison reingestartet sind, und ich finde, jetzt ist ja meistens irgendwie so, Ende Oktober kann man erst einmal so ein kleines Zwischenfazit nach neun oder zehn Spielen auch mit dem Blick auf die Tabelle und die anderen Wettbewerbe machen. Und da muss ich sagen, nee, das überzeugt mich. Deswegen diesmal MVP an der Seitenlinie.
Sehr, sehr stark. Erst fünf Gegentreffer, Inter am 26.11. spielt man gegen Juve. Das war das erste, was ich jetzt nachgeguckt habe, als hier zum wiederholten Male Inter gehypt wurde. Fabian, wer ist denn da aktuell dein MVP?
Ich hätte mich jetzt mehr einfach machen können und auf Griezmann tippen können, der letzte Woche glaube ich einen Hedgwick erzielt hat. Aber ich habe mich für einen Spieler von Chirona entschieden, die ja nach wie vor Tabellen zweiter sind. Und zwar dem ukrainischen Stürmer Artem Dovbik, wenn ich das jetzt richtig ausgesprochen habe. War eigentlich nicht so wirklich auf der Liste, glaube ich, bei den Leuten, auch nicht bei mir. Hat aber inzwischen schon fünf Saison-Tore, zwei Vorlagen. Ist so eine Hühne, die da vorne drin steht und die Dinger macht am Wochenende 2 gegen Almeria, nachdem man 0-2 weg zurückklickt, haben sie noch 5-2 gewonnen. Und, ja, Girona, muss ich sagen, macht das richtig stark bisher.
Punktgleich sind sie doch, glaube ich, mit Real. Ich habe die Tabelle mir hier gerade weggeklickt. 25 Punkte, 8 Siege, ein Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Wer sich mehr noch zu Girona informieren möchte, am 28.09. haben wir in der Liga Tour mit Alex da auch noch ausführlicher darüber gesprochen. Uli, wer ist dein aktueller MVP?
Ich nehme jetzt auch mal einen einzelnen Spieler und bleibe jetzt mal bei Aston Villa und will mal einen Namen nennen, der auch theoretisch aus Ansagen Hero hätte durchgehen können, aber nicht so sehr, wenn man viel Premier League guckt. Douglas Luiz, den kennt man vielleicht aus deutschen Schlagzeilen, weil er mal mit Alicia Lehmann zusammen war. Das ist glaube ich auch das Einzige, was in Deutschland je über ihn berichtet worden ist. War on-off, also für die, die Boulevard interessiert sind, will ich auch mal zu haben. Nee, aber jetzt im Ernst, also ich habe da keine Ahnung, ich muss da auch nochmal nachschauen, sind die noch zusammen oder nicht? Keine Ahnung, gibt es das? Ist so ein 6er-8er Hybrid, ist ein echt physisch starker Spieler, hat aber kranker Ballstriker, also wirklich Schusstechniken aller Arten, sei es jetzt direkter Abschluss oder auch Ecken, der dreht regelmäßig Ecken rein, also wirklich stark, grundsätzlich technisch sehr stark, hat manchmal so eine gewisse Wurschtigkeit an sich, die einen echt auch wahnsinnig werden lässt, lässt sich dann im Spiel manchmal hängen, da das aber gerade überhaupt gar nicht hart und sogar noch torgefährlich geworden ist, ist das einer, der ein wesentlicher Faktor ist. Ich finde aber, die machen ihre Sache gut, stehen im Moment über dem Strich. Das ist der mit Abstand schwächste Kader der Liga, da muss man nichts dazu erzählen. Und wenn ich dann gleich über einen Panzo erzähle, dann weiß man aber warum. Aber die machen ihre Sache sehr, sehr gut. Und ein Panzo, aus dem Grund einer, der mal genannt werden muss, die Geschichte hat man vielleicht gelesen, der ist im Dezember 2013 zu looten gekommen, damals in die Non-League und ist der erste Spieler, der es geschafft hat, aus dem englischen de facto Amateurbereich in die Premier League hochzugehen. Ohne den Verein zu wechseln. Genau, das an sich ist schon mal eine Leistung, aber dass der jetzt auf das Level kommt, finde ich total erstaunlich. Der hat sich Jahr für Jahr verbessert, da waren natürlich auch mal Jahre drin, wo sie in der selben Liga waren, aber er hat sich Jahr für Jahr verbessert und ist von einem unterdurchschnittlichen Fußballspieler, der eigentlich gar keine Profizukunft mehr hatte, zu einem Premier League Stammspieler geworden, der seine Sache richtig gut macht. Und man sagt den Gluten, das ist der Wipes-Man in der Kabine, also derjenige, der auch noch dazu für die gute Stimmung sorgt, der auch die Neuen onboardet. Deswegen muss der mal genannt werden, weil es mich total erstaunt ist, dass er auch den letzten Schritt, an dem dann viele scheitern, die einen ähnlichen Weg machen, noch geschafft hat, nämlich sich wirklich auch in der Premier League zu zeigen.
Jetzt muss er nur noch ein Tor schießen, das hat er glaube ich noch nicht geschafft in der Premier League, oder? Habe ich das übersehen? Ich glaube, er schiebt noch ein Tor.
Das glaube ich nicht. Die haben allgemein nicht so ganz viele Tore, sondern das läuft eher über ein aggressives Gegenarbeiten. Aber ich, also Looten, hätte ich nie gedacht, dass die, die werden nicht kampflos runtergehen. Lass das mal sicher.
Stark. Peli Rodak Mpanzo. Wer bei YouTube zugeguckt hat, der hat gesehen, wie ich in der Sekunde panisch einen Tab geöffnet habe. Und sehr dankbar war, als du gesagt hast, Looten. Ah, okay, dann wusste ich auch, wo ich suchen muss. Hatte ich nicht auf dem Schirm. Fabian, wen habe ich denn in La Liga nicht auf dem Schirm?
Ein Ansanchiro, oder? Genau, dann waren wir noch bei baskischen Trainer, dann habe ich auch ein Gegenbeispiel, ein schönes, nämlich Galska Caritano, der hat vor ein paar Spieltagen Almeria übernommen und hat bisher noch nichts gerissen. War ein interessanter Trainer eigentlich. War Spieler übrigens auch von San Sebastian, hat dann Ewa ziemlich stark trainiert in der zweiten, aber auch in der ersten Liga. Hat danach auch mal Athletic Bilbao bekommen als Trainerstation, da hat er das aber auch nicht gerissen. Und jetzt hat er mal wieder einen Job bekommen in Almeria und da läuft es auch nicht so gut. Also ich glaube, bei dem geht es wirklich steil bergab, was die Trainerkarriere anbelangt.
Also am Anfang aber auch kein Hero, habe ich das gerade richtig verstanden. Rightfully Neglected.
Ein Unsung Anti-Hero sozusagen.
Man wird hier doch immer wieder überrascht.
Bayer, was hast du uns mitgebracht? Ein Spieler, der im Sommer von Donatskas Treda, dem ehemaligen Verein von Peter Hibala, Tomislav Maric, Werner Lorand und Bernd Stork, das weil ich es einfach getrobbt habe, nach Italien gekommen ist. Nikola Kristović, Stürmer der montenecrinischen Nationalmannschaft, 23 Jahre jung, spielt bei Lecce, die ja tatsächlich als auch mit den Aufstärkern als Abstiegskandidat Nummer 1 gehandelt wurden, die sich jetzt nach einem sehr guten Saisonstart auch wieder um jetzt ein paar Linerlagen aber gefangen haben. Spielstarker, Beidfüßiger, Stürmer, 4 Tore schon gemacht in 8 Partien und das bei einem Verein wie Lecce also mit dafür verantwortlich, dass die aktuell überhaupt gar keine Abstiegssorgen haben.
Christovic, weiß man, ob der dann auch, war das nicht bei Serbien, Montenegro so? Ach Gott, wie heißt die Legende? Ne, ach ich hab's gerade mit Nordmazedonien verwechselt. Sorry, vergesst alles, was ich sage.
Er hat jetzt aber gegen Serbien gespielt, auf jeden Fall, da haben sie verloren.
Jaja, genau, ich hatte es gerade, weil sein Name war mir über den Weg gelaufen. Ja, ich hab's gerade aber völlig, diese Abzweigung war falsch, aber ich hab's ja noch gemerkt. Deswegen, Moment des Spieltags oder der Woche, Mario, das gleich weitermachen.
Ja, dann mach ich nochmal kurz den Bogen zu unserem ersten Thema. Der Moment der Woche war Stefan El-Sharawi, der den vierten Pflichtspiel-Sieg für die Roma mit einem 1-0-Sieg-Treffer in der 90. Minute gegen Monza eingetütet hat und nach dem Spiel dann in, oder direkt im Anschluss in Tränen ausgebrochen ist, denn auch er war einer, der stand jetzt zu Unrecht beschuldigt wurde und der in den letzten Wochen auch viel Druck aushalten musste rund um die Wettgeschichte. Also das war schön, aber auch traurig zu sehen. Das war beides. Das waren Tränen der Erleichterung und, oder, aber auf jeden Fall ein Moment, so der halt eben auf dem Sportplatz dann geparkt mit viel Emotionen entsteht.
Ja, absolut. Fabian, welchen Moment möchtest du uns noch mitgeben? Oder hast du einen Anti-Moment mitgebracht? Die 37.
Es gibt in Spanien eine ziemlich gute Fernsehsendung, die immer den Spieltag beleuchtet. El día después, der Tag danach heißt die. Und die machen immer ziemlich schöne Geschichten. Und da ist mir diese Woche eine sehr schöne Geschichte aufgefallen. Und zwar ist dort in Osasuna war das, in einem Heimspiel, das erste Mal Vater und Tochter zusammen ins Stadion gegangen. Die Tochter war da wohl schon öfter der Vater das erste Mal, denn der ist nämlich blind gewesen. Und dann hat die Kamera darauf gehalten, wie die beiden das Spiel zusammen verfolgen. Und der Vater ist auch großer Osasuna-Fan, aber man kann es natürlich nicht sehen. Die Tochter hat ihm dann immer ein bisschen erklärt, wie es gerade so läuft. Das war wohl auch ziemlich spannend. Osasuna hat das Ding dann noch gewonnen. Und beide waren wohl ziemliche Fans von Jimmy Avila. Und dann hat die Tochter gesagt, jetzt läuft der Jimmy hier direkt bei uns vorbei. Und da ist er und so weiter. Und er so, wow. Und das war sehr emotional, das Ganze. Und ja, es war einfach ein schöner Moment, wie man da so zwei Personen gesehen hat, die zusammen Fußball genießen, obwohl der eine ja eigentlich nicht sehen kann. Aber er hat die Emotionen im Stadion mitgenommen und er war natürlich dementsprechend auch gerührt. Und es gab da noch einen schönen Nachdreh. Denn Jimmy Avila hat es gesehen, den Bericht wohl anscheinend und sucht jetzt die beiden und möchte sich mit denen treffen. Und das hat zwar noch nicht stattgefunden, aber ich bin mir sicher, da gibt es noch ein richtig schönes Happy End. Gute Frage, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Aber ein sehr schöner Moment des Spieltags. Und das knüpft auch an eine Power-Hörerin, deren Lieblingsformat ist. Ganz herzliche Grüße an Pina. Sie liebt die Ligatur. Die Ligatur ist die einzige Folge vom Rasenfunk, die sie immer in der Chronologie vorzieht. Ansonsten hört sie alles vom Rasenfunk chronologisch. Und wir haben mit Pina mal ein Tribüngespräch gemacht, wie es ist, als Blinde im Fußballstadion zu sein, weil sie schon seit den 80ern in deutschen Fußballstadien, in Unterhaching, im Olympiastadion und so weiter unterwegs war. Und da gab es logischerweise noch keinen Kommentar für Menschen, die nicht sehen können. Und da hat sie einfach zum Teil Leute angesprochen, hat gesagt, hier erzähl mir mal, was passiert. Total faszinierend, werde ich verlinken. War ein sehr schönes Tribüngespräch. Pina, herzliche Grüße an der Stelle. Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir das an der Stelle hier nur machen.
Bin mir aber sicher, dass es das gibt, eigentlich in Spanien, wo ich drüber nachdenke, es gibt auch Fußball-Kommentate für, na wie sagt man, für Hörgeschädigte, wo dann in Gebär... Entschuldigung, ich weiß nicht, wie man es nennt. Das Ganze kommentiert wird und allgemein ist Spanien sehr behindertenfreundlich, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Die machen ziemlich viele gute Sachen. Und ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass es dann auch für blinde Fußball-Kommentare gibt.
In Sicherheit.
Sehr gut. Mensch, was wir hier immer noch für Themen mitmachen. Ich mag die Ligatur auch. So, jetzt wird uns Uli noch rauswerfen mit seinem Moment.
Ja, das tue ich wirklich, weil ich die Stimmung ein wenig drücke. Ich leime mir mal einen Moment aus der Champions League aus. Und der wird dann auch sicherlich übergehen, aber ins nächste Wochenende. Sir Bobby Charlton ist verstorben. Am Samstag. Die Nachricht kam im Verlauf des Spieltags, kurz vor dem Manchester City Spiel. Da ist dann schon gedacht worden. Also improvisiert sozusagen. Was dann auch nochmal zeigt, wie landesübergreifend Sir Bobby Charlton gewirkt hat. Also das kann man sich hier gar nicht vorstellen in Deutschland. Wie wichtig der für den englischen Fußball war als Weltmeister 66, als Überlebender des Flugzeugabsturzes von 58 über München, als dann spätere Europapokalsieger, also originales Busby Babe und dann auch zum Sir geworden, einer der großen Gentlemans des Sports. Und diese Schweigeminuten in der Champions League am Mittwoch in Manchester und sämtliche Kommentare aus der gesamten Fußballwelt, die nochmal einfach klar gemacht haben, wie wichtig dieser Mann, dieser Fußballspieler war und ist und bleiben wird, die fand ich sehr ergreifend. Das ist etwas, das in England einfach besser funktioniert als hier in Deutschland, finde ich. Der Umgang mit den wirklich Großen in dem Sport. Und ich bin sehr gespannt. Am Wochenende steht es Manchester Dabian. Was da passieren wird, ist irgendwie tragisch schön, dass dieses Manchester Dabie das erste Heimspiel nach seinem Ableben dann in der Premier League genau da hinfällt und dass das noch mal so wirkt, als wäre es eine Celebration seines gesamten Lebens. Also großen Respekt vor Sir Bobby Chiton, auch einer der ersten Namen, logischerweise, die man bekommen hat, wenn man sich ansatzweise mit englischem Fußball auseinandersetzt.
Aber absolut. Ich dachte ehrlicherweise als Kind ganz lange, dass Sir ein Vorname wäre, ein Englischer. Wegen Sir Bobby Chiton, weil der damals im Kicker immer wieder vorkam auf den internationalen Seiten. Und ich halt jede Seite im Kicker gelesen habe. Und da dachte ich, Sir wäre einfach Vorname. Und dann hießen ja auch andere Sir. Das war für mich Sir Elton John. Da dachte ich mir, ja klar, das ist halt irgendwie so ein Doppelname. Und ich will nicht verraten, wie alt ich war, als ich das verstanden habe. So ist es dann doch nicht. Und das ist meine Verbindung zu Sir Bobby Chiton. Ja, vielen Dank. Das war jetzt auch nochmal ein richtig wichtiger Schwenk. Weil gefühlt ist es schon wieder zwei Wochen her, aber es war ja erst am letzten Wochenende. Weil schon so viele fantastische Texte dazu erschienen sind. Und andere Dinge.
Darf ich da Uli was fragen dazu noch? Und zwar... In der Champions League war es ja erst eine Schweigeminute. Glaubst du, es gibt beim Derby dann einen Minute auf Applaus?
Also die Engländer interpretieren es ja nur mal anders. Ich tippe auch mal. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht. Ich bin noch nicht so weit, aber ich würde tippen, die gesamte Liga macht das. Man sagt ja immer, Minute der Reflektion. Das ist in aller Regel eine Feier des Lebens quasi. Das ist ja auch wesentlich schöner einfach, als zu schweigen. Jetzt kommt ja der Remembrance Month in England. Das heißt, die Zeremonien an die Gedenken der Weltkriegsopfer, die kommen ja jetzt auch an dem Wochenende normalerweise. Das heißt, da gibt es dann sowieso schon mal immer die Mondblumen, dann die Blaskapelle. Also ich weiß nicht, wie man das richtig bezeichnet. Da bin ich raus. Und dann der Marsch, der Einmarsch und so. Und ich würde tippen, dass es dann ziemlich sicher, vielleicht sogar noch gar nicht losgeht an dem Wochenende, auch wenn es Tradition ist, sondern auf jeden Fall Minute des Applauses. Und das wird dann meistens, ja, werden es ja zwei, drei Minuten. Also insbesondere Manchester wird es so sein. Und da freue ich mich irgendwie so. Es klingt komisch, mobile, aber ich freue mich darauf, dass einfach so jemand hochgehalten wird und das Andenken an so jemanden hochgehalten wird.
Ja, ich kann verstehen, auch wenn es jetzt komisch anhört, wie du es gemeint hast gerade. Aber diese Minuten des Applauses sind schon immer sehr ergreifend und haben gleich irgendwie auch was energetischeres als Schweigeminuten, in denen dann irgendein Sufkopf reinschreit, zumindest in deutschen Stadien.
Ja, und gleichzeitig zeigt einem das auch schon so, wie viel man schon mit dem Fußball erlebt hat, finde ich immer wieder. Also ich habe jetzt hier so meine Bobby-Tarten-Geschichte erzählt. Noch ältere Menschen haben ganz, ganz andere Bilder dazu im Kopf. Und das zeigt einem immer, wie viel man auch schon erlebt hat und wie viel man dann doch mit diesem Sport verbindet, trotz all der Probleme, die wir hier ja auch thematisiert haben. Also wenn das jetzt mal nicht eine runde Legatur war, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde da draußen, dann weiß ich es auch nicht. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlichen Dank an Fabian Pakulat. Danke dir. Mario Rieker, ich werde natürlich alles verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Danke dir, Mario. Und herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Und muss nur noch updaten, wo ihr jetzt überall seid, Blue Sky, Mastodon und so weiter. Es ist ja alles so kompliziert geworden. Aber einfach ist geblieben, dass man den Rasenfunk unter rasenfunk.de finden kann. Ich werde in den Show notes verlinken, sowohl den Glücklich Süchtig Podcast als auch das Bügengespräch mit Pina. Und dann danke ich euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclubkönnt ihr dem supporters club beitreten und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr euch Beanie, Foodies und so weiter für den Winter kaufen, wenn ihr möchtet. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.